- We live in a beautiful
world surrounded by genius.
(water gurgles)
Shark skin is antimicrobial
and reduces drag.
Lotus leaf plants have
self-cleaning surfaces.
Peacock feathers create
color without pigment.
Gecko foot pads create
adhesion without adhesives.
I've always been fascinated
by the natural world.
Number one, I see the inherent beauty,
but secondly, on a deeper
level I look and I see possible
solution sets to design challenges.
I'm Maria O'Farrell and I'm
a biomimicry professional.
And what that means is it's my job
to go into companies and help them solve
design challenges using 3.8 billion years
of research and development
from the natural world.
(techno music)
- My name's Kevin Beck
and I work at Lenovo.
Engineering is ultimately
all about iteration.
You rarely get anything
right the first time.
You build it and you test it
and you figure out what's wrong with it
and then you improve it
and you do that again,
and again, and again, and again,
but nature's been doing
that for billions of years.
So sometimes it helps
to sort of skip ahead
in the process and see what
solution nature came up with.
That's what biomimicry is all about;
taking the best of nature and seeing
if we can somehow adapt that
to solve a technology problem.
So here's a good example
of how this works.
We've got a thermal and cooling engineer,
who's faced with a
reasonably large challenge
of creating a new type of fan
to go into a new all-in-one desktop.
By necessity it has to
be really, really thin,
but also be really, really quiet.
So this engineer took his son
to the aquarium on a Saturday.
And there was a dolphin show.
(dolphin clicks)
So he's sitting there
watching the dolphin show
and he notices that when
they come out of the water
and they go back into the water,
it's a very clean exit
and a very clean entry
because of the shape of their body.
- Dolphins evolved a design strategy
so that they could move
through the water quickly
with the least amount of
noise to capture their prey.
- He had this kind of
ah-ha moment that said,
hmm, if they're that efficient in water,
I wonder if that structure might
also work for a fan in air?
- Water has 500 times the
frictional drag that air does.
So if you found something
that can do it in water,
it stands to reason that you found
a pretty good design for the air.
- So he goes back and sort of mocks up
this design in his CAD program.
(whimsical music)
It didn't work very well at all,
the first, second, third,
fourth, fifth time,
but he finally got to something
that actually works really, really well.
There's a fan blade and on the ends
of the tips of the blades,
there’s a little structure
that looks kinda like a dolphin's body
that are very efficient at
moving air and very, very quiet.
There are a number of other examples
of biomimicry in Lenovo products as well.
Stands inspired by the
shape of an orchid stem.
Fans inspired by the
shape of an owl's wing.
(air rushes against wings)
Cooling vents inspired by
the honeycomb structure of a beehive.
Each of these designs have all in some way
been made better by biomimicry.
- We are natural beings, we are animals.
And I think a lot of the problems
that we face are tied
indelibly to the fact
that we have divorced
ourselves from nature.
But the good news is,
again as a young species,
that we have a lot of mentors
in evolutionary elders
and a life's operating
manual that we can consult.
All of the solutions we seek
out are right in front of us.
We're surrounded by genius.
(techno music)